[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning Tosun live and in living
color it's Tuesday live from New York
it's Tuesday morning we are back I in
fact on American soil back and at home
and the arms of my son it feels so right
how was your travels oh my god this was
one of the harder legs we've ever done
it was one of the longer ones the max
I've ever done like without coming home
as three cities but this was you know
six hours away in the Pacific Northwest
not really like our target demographic
really expanding my my mic crowd and
really beating you know this material to
a pulp and it was good it was really
fine by the way Portland is it like it's
one of those towns it's what you thought
Cleveland was like it's so clean they
had the bird we burned it hurt it's
pretty like a hipster like knows what
they're doing yeah there was like a
Louie Vuitton or like right across the
street from our hotel it was very chic
very toasty obviously and really just a
good town for you to keep on your list a
little too far from New York like
six-hour flight no thank you
a little too far um and then we went to
Seattle which we didn't even get one
minute in Seattle we were in and out I
saw you wearing a public market sure so
Ben has had this t-shirt like forever
it's like always want I sleep in or like
do my makeup in and I was going to
Seattle and I'm like I have to bring my
public market shirt at this point it
literally needs to be quarantined
because I wore it like on every good
long car ride every plane it to sleep
like it smells so bad this was like the
one t-shirt I brought to hang out in and
it's so [ __ ] nasty now like it needs
to be thrown away I totally thought
someone that gifted it to you know that
is so I wasn't the beard
hey snatchler welcome back hey how's the
TM the tour manager it's great she got
us over the border in minutes that was
the most surprising I did not think they
would let a snatch her across country
lines and then back again it was
actually crazy I don't think I've ever
driven over like a border no very we're
the Millers yes
okay I didn't I don't know the reference
but I usually do that movie no I told
you I walked out of it oh my god it's so
good I don't see it as everyone else
says I find it kind of annoying oh my
god what a crew Jennifer Aniston or girl
as much as I love friends I find like
post friends Jennifer Aniston's movie
career like to be annoying and I don't
really support it well that's not an
untrue statement yeah but this film is
gonna be on Emma Roberts Jason Sudeikis
the accountant from um The Hangover I
never saw it I just like III wasn't
loving it in the movie and when I'm in a
movie theater I have a very low
threshold like if I don't like you
Hoppus if I'm not in it like get me out
of here like I already feel so uneasy
being in movie theaters these days and
you know how I realize that me and Margo
went to the movies in Vancouver we had a
day off we went to see good boys which
was did you see it no but I'm actually
see I cannot believe you haven't seen it
like it is there's so many movies out I
saw ad astra so me and Margo went to the
movies and honestly like I was feeling
so relaxed like it was just like you
know when you're in a movie theater in
America like you're always looking over
your shoulder like we've actually left
movie theaters yes
I don't feel that way anymore ever since
the elevation of the movie theater
experience with like I pick and some of
the nicer movie theaters because I feel
like if you're gonna like know like this
is awful but if you're gonna shoot up a
movie theater like it's not gonna be the
most expensive wine right but me and
Margo well then I said it me and Martin
went to mean we're going to a standard
movie theater like another line that I
can't do and I haven't felt like so at
ease in a movie theater in so long and
then I realized I'm like oh we crossed
the border like things are different in
Vancouver it was so relaxing like so
normal it was just like a day at the
movies yeah it's a good time oh my god
such a good time I love the movies and
every time I go to the movies I'm like I
should go more I know I'm like then
you're like start to get crazy or like
[ __ ] I used to do a double header you
know that's so funny that you said I was
my dream of asking Margo if we wanted to
see something else like Hustler's I'll
tell you you see my dream to see a
doubleheader and one day my dreams came
true and I saw two movies in one day and
it was actually too overwhelming I
didn't have enough time to process the
first movie then I go into the second
movie like with my head still in the
first movie and I just couldn't
appreciate the second film and so you
know what there's such thing as too much
of a good thing yeah and then you
away from your son for too long yes but
he's with his hands me chest being so
well taken care of well it was so
painful like this weekend everyone was
home this weekend like hang out with
Theo all you guys were hanging out and I
was just like a way for my family and I
I never felt so far away from home
yeah well at least you were with the
snatchler whose family yeah that's true
thank you sure you got real close this
weekend did you it was a lot of together
time a little too close for comfort
see the thing is it's like I'm when it
comes to family when it comes to other
people like don't touch me ever but when
it comes to family like I don't get sick
of family you know like I I saw Marvin
this morning and I was like my name is
see so much and I literally saw her at 7
p.m. last night
yeah I mean it's like a 12-hour reprieve
it's in a chain like that like I could
tell what I gave such a hug this morning
she was like hurtling up and like she
wasn't ready to see me yet you know but
it's okay I accept you and love you for
who you are so did she know I think it's
time this Mitch last night and I was
actually becoming fearful like on the
phone I think I'm gonna hang up before I
could screamed up she's just she's built
you know like a snatch yeah but there's
nothing like that love and snatch before
we dive into the Fast Five I want to
catch up because I watched Kardashians
okay and I would love to hear your take
on the Cory Campbell thing because like
very low-key I'm kind of on Cory Gamble
side okay this is gonna be like a
controversial conversation and I've
thought about it ever since I watched
Yepez ode yesterday I was like should I
say how I feel right that's what we do
on the show people aren't even gonna
agree with me um but I do think that
generally speaking like kids need to be
spanked sometimes and I go to your
grandma's boyfriend to spank you totally
that's why I'm not a hundred percent on
his side because then it would be like
oh I don't want to leave my kid with my
grandma's boyfriend because they're
gonna get spanked and I don't even think
that yeah but like their philosophy of
like and total some of the toasters were
like there was a lot a lot of
conversation about and people were like
abusing children shouldn't be a solution
like a spanking is not abuse I agree and
a lot of people reporting out we're
pointing out that it's definitely like a
cultural difference between the way Cory
grew up in the way the Kardashians grew
up and here's the thing whether it seems
like Kim and and Khloe spank their kids
no it seems like they're a little bit
more strict then I didn't get the vibe
that they said they spanked
you know cuz I got the vibe that they
were kind of judging Courtney for being
like so laissez-faire with the kids know
when Kim was talking to Jonathan and she
was like Chloe and I have had this
conversation about like whether or not
Courtney should like I don't know that
Kate such a crazy conversation throughs
too young to ever have been spanked for
like I don't know if Kim has ever
spanked her kids but it's definitely on
the table and it's definitely like
threatened and they're more powerful
than a spanked great retina of a speck I
agree and so whether or not you agree
that spanking is like a good thing to do
like it was just really a conversation
do I think that Cori meant that he was
gonna you know pull his pants down and
hit her in the ass no I think he was
just saying like that's what you gotta
do you know cuz that's how he grew up
and like honestly I didn't I didn't
think when he was saying was so crazy
you know until Scott like had this crazy
reaction almost like it was triggering
something in this you're talking to like
a pacifist
also all that being said we don't have
kids I do not know what I'm gonna do
when I have kids and I have a little
precious bit and yeah she scratched me
but like she's the cutest thing ever
like total how can I thank her so I'm
just I'm saying like theoretically what
I would do but in practice it's a lot
different no not only that it's like the
conversation isn't whether or not you
think spanking is good or bad like
that's a parent's choice like it's it's
a dangerous choice the conversation
though that I think is important is like
the judgment element like I don't think
Scott's reaction was warranted because I
don't think that Cori meant that he was
gonna be the one to do it he did mean
that and he said it like up down he
clarified he meant that is Penelope if
he was babysitting Penelope like the
babysitter was and Penelope scratched
him and took a chunk of skin from face
he would have spanked her on the spot
because she needs to be reprimanded for
what she did in that moment not like a
few days later not a conversation and
even the way that they were dealing with
Mason just showed like kids need to it's
kind of like when you're training Theo
like if he misbehaves you don't punish
him a little while later after you've
sorted out the punishment
because then he doesn't know what it was
it makes it less perfect yes the net
with Mason's Mason's older he can
understand but Penelope is younger you
should know scratch means slap right
well I would know so when i gamble isn't
the one to be doing the spanking it was
just a really interesting conversation
and it really it like proves like how
like how really far we've come I feel
like back in the day like
I when I was in you know school I would
see some kid I knew he was getting a
spankin like it wasn't a big deal it was
like a part of growing up I guess
no it's always been a weird I think it's
a more the time passes in the more at
2019 we become and then you know 20 21
21 like it's a really weird conversation
right and like people regard it as abuse
yes and like if you were someone who
grew up with spankings you did not tell
your friends you've got to say like haha
it's humiliating and to like it it does
sound concerning you tell the wrong
friends well you a sudden you have child
services at your door very private
no thing that happens in families Jackie
I can totally agree but it's just it's
also like a slight to children who are
actually abuse like agreed like a pat on
the ass is not in any way abuse like and
I think that that's really like a
dangerous road to go down do you know
any more than 2% it takes and like there
just have to be consequences for your
actions in it the very least there
should be fear this is just such an
interesting conversation and I'm so
shook that like the world is not talking
about it because it's the Kardashian
know and I'm so I'm so glad they aired
that conversation they could have easily
not like it doesn't make Cory look good
it doesn't make Chris look good and they
could have just like stayed away from it
but I think it's an interesting
conversation because it's like one of
those things that nobody talks about I
don't know I just feel like kids should
be raised and I feel like we were with
like a strong amount of like love mostly
but a little bit of fear like you should
be scared of your parents and you should
be scared to step out of line that's not
good intent do it but like you don't you
don't make the same mistake twice
like you you know you don't scratch
somewhat again you don't have kids so
we're you know but like so when I am NOT
I mean if I say my she's probably not
gonna tell you guys but just in theory
like there needs to be like and taking
someone's phone away like she was saying
that works for Mason it doesn't work for
Penelope and then I saw these toasters
saying well my parents used to take my
door off and that really changed me you
should take her door and it's like
that's not gonna work forever like
sometimes yeah some kids aren't like
attached to things
yeah like Penelope doesn't even need a
door yeah she's tiny yeah yeah she
shouldn't have to order yeah you know it
which is a very interesting conversation
it was also really good episode like I
was
it was such a good app I was shook by
the fact that that was a prank me to see
that coming me too
oh my god and the footage at first when
I thought it was real I was like holy
[ __ ] and I was actually really surprised
that Kim was like dedicated an entire
episode to her security protocol because
she was kind of giving a little too much
information she was like we have three
guards in the front and three at the
gate and three and I thought she was
like literally giving him like a robber
like the keys to the back end of her
house maybe she was lying it's like a
setup maybe probably wants people to
think that and she probably has even
more going on yeah that was crazy and
like the way that everyone like acts
like they're too good for the security
like Jonathan and Courtney just get the
house just do what you have to do you
know - Kim's house Jonathan was being
awful I didn't like how he was yelling
at people but do you see even the
audience at Dancing with the Stars last
yeah he was Allie Brooks family and fret
he wasn't Lamar's family and friends
though but I did think that that was an
interesting conversation maybe for sure
Allie Brooke likes it harmony yeah and
he changed his name officially to food
god that's what the party was like what
a sad birthday party and then I realized
wasn't a real birthday it was a change
yes that when you go from destiny hope
to Miley yeah and it was you know ruined
obviously by you know the big
conversation of corporal punishment yeah
an interesting one nonetheless I'm the
good episode and it really gave me a
huge appreciation oh my god wait sorry
this is before I went to bed last night
I said we have to talk about this on the
toast when Courtney I'm sorry when Chloe
Kylie and Chris were on the jet going to
Napa and they were talking about her
like when you have grandchildren and
Kris like started to cry she's like and
Chloe was like I don't want to talk
about that stuff because I can makes me
really sad like to think that like
things are gonna be different like that
conversation made me like so much you
know like we have had that conversation
before like how you don't want to talk
about the future because like it's a
happy and stuff but it's also really sex
like things are gonna change and like
people die and it's just like so sad and
I really like felt that connection with
them when they were having that
conversation on the plane
no safe and that Kris was crying I know
everyone thought she was being dramatic
but like she was I was crying too
they're talking about what they're gonna
do at Stormy's 40 I think Kris is like
I'm not gonna be there that's so sad to
think about yeah that's really sad to
think about I love Chris like I actually
have a huge Kris Jenner appreciation
like I know everyone does but like in
recent history just like really I'm
standing like the magic that is Kris
Jenner 100% are you frying we're go
no-hit birthday and then also I watched
oh you don't want Potomac but I watched
Potomac and did you talk about the Emmys
on yesterday's episode yes we did
because I watch the whole thing but we
have a bit of Emmys related so I'll get
all your thoughts the snitch and I
watched the red carpet I need to like
give him as your shout out to Tommy rod
and Justin who did such a good job I
would say arguably a better job than the
main hosts who were actually on the
carpet they were at the entrance they
secured the one and only interview with
sophie Turner because sophie Turner has
friends at on your ad and indistinct in
really the future of the E Network and I
really enjoyed it I only saw them on the
tail end of the Sophie interview where
Tanya was talking about how excited to
us that she got a so V interview and I
thought it was cool that it's like they
break the fourth wall where it's like oh
my god she's my friend so like she
talked to us and that's so cool like
where it's Juliana like we don't know
how she knows these people does she know
them is she French names everyone the
double kiss is she friends with anyone
offline so I thought it was like a cool
element that I mean we bring that to the
CMAs all the time all the time we will
be bringing it this year again yes but
we've never brought that to the Emmys
and they did and I enjoyed me too I can
I can happen to catch you too okay folks
out further ado I think it's time for
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast and I did
agree your chomp was not rounded enough
thank you exactly what you meant cuz
she'd finish it then I was like oh she
was just going yeah yeah no she was
going like straight and it needed a
little more of a rounding I completely
agree so battered exactly what you're
talking you did a great job snitch but I
know you thought you sounded crazy
I didn't II what you meant thank you and
I wanted to let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by
modern fertility now I'll just power and
when you know more you can make better
decisions for your body your health and
your future
there aren't many decisions bigger than
having a child but for many women
fertility is a big question mark if you
want more information about your
fertility and your ability to get
pregnant you need modern fertility it's
a quick and easy hormone test you can
take it home whether you're thinking I'm
trying for a baby now or you want to
know your options for the future your
results are delivered within 10 days in
your personalized dashboard will give
you insight into how many eggs you have
hormone levels and reproductive red
flags you could also talk one-on-one
with the fertility nurse or you
the time line tool to plan ahead
proactive testing through your doctor
can cost over a thousand dollars but
with modern fertility you can get the
same information for just one hundred
and fifty nine dollars and right now
modern fertility is offering our
listeners $20 off the test when you go
to modern fertility calm / toast that's
$20 off your fertility tests when you go
to modern fertility calm / toast modern
fertility calm / toast love it
Ricky Videla just commented the cutest
thing what do you think when we pass we
can have a toast reunion I want to die
and go to camp toast seem actually
because I was on the west coast this
weekend I got at Ming greets like 1
million questions about west coast camp
coast and I know we haven't really
talked about it a lot just because we're
like so hell-bent on getting East Coast
camp chose to be like the best that it
could be but I do think it's something
worth exploring like a punch strings for
sure and I guess then we would have to
go in and to our campsites and I guess I
could be persuaded that's like the best
part of the job and when we have camp
tests in heaven it'll be called Camp
ghosts ok oh my god conversations like
that like always make me cry that's how
the song in case you don't live forever
by been pot always makes me cry like
just always makes me cry I can't even
like I put on the album the other day
and I'm just like just waiting I
couldn't even hear the beginning of that
song do you want to hear something
second version of the album without the
song for people who don't agree yeah
because it's very triggering you wanna
hear something so upsetting we've been
talking about going to the Ben pie
concert at Radio City Music Hall for
like months it's on Rosh Hashanah
that's so not been class I know he went
to romaji bush camp with bed yeah it's
which night of restaurant is it second
right oh Sunday night the first night
are you crying snitch no surname oh man
it's really annoying that is really
annoying but you know I don't think I
could handle it like mentally
emotionally especially I'm such a
sensitive time like Rosh Hashanah right
like during the ten days before Yom
Kippur you guys co me before I just
snuck up on us always done a did I get
always it's always your mojo no Yom
Kippur is the Jewish holiday that is
once a year where you have to fast for
the whole day and it's literally the
worst day of the year you have to atone
for all your sins you can't wear makeup
you can't wear leather you can't eat
anything you shouldn't brush your teeth
but like I do low-key because like I'm a
disgusting guys um and it just makes the
day like a little bit better it's
literally the
today at the air you can't watch TV you
can't get in the car like it's the most
pin inducing day of all time and I
actually think the lead-up to Yom Kippur
is actually worse than Yom Kippur
because the fasting part is like there's
only a few hours where it's torture like
the ones before you go to sleep and the
ones like before you break your to five
o'clock yeah two to five o'clock but
like not being on the phone and just
like the lead up thinking about the pit
that you're gonna have because you have
to think about all of your year worth of
sins and it's just like oh I'm a
terrible person like someone should
spank I'm gonna make apology and yet so
that's coming up and I just feel like we
hadn't talked about it yet no I know
because I was trying I feel like if you
don't talk about it like it won't come
no I know but then if it just c7 we're
not prepared
we lost prepared laughs oh my god I
don't have to overhype it so that it's
like hey that wasn't so bad
yeah you know I can't do the toasts like
it's literally the worst day ever
yeah what day of the week is it on I
think it's in the middle of the week I
guess it's better than a weekend we get
to like miss a day of work I guess it's
like silver lining Wednesday October 9
Wednesday that's a perfect day I'd
rather do an episode of 12 straight
hours of toast and we can eat of course
I love doing the toast to sleep in and
then we go it'll be a week where we go
from working like to Monday Tuesday and
then Thursday Friday that's kind of a
nice cool week they actually shouldn't
think of doing that like Wednesday
Saturday Sunday weekends yeah breaks it
up yeah we'll see how it goes okay
okay first story um speaking of modern
fertility Jenna Dewan is pregnant with
her first child with her boyfriend Steve
Kazee
not her first child overall her first
child with her boyfriend these two
really just washed our hands and get the
[ __ ] out of like each other and they
seemed to me really amicably like doing
that because they're both super happy is
you know Channing Tatum Chinese day with
Jessie J which I thought was a weird
pairing but the like the longer they
stay together the more I believe in
their love oh my god it's so real and so
pure and I love them it just makes me
want happiness for his ex you know here
it is happiness on a platter
did anyone watch new movie that she's in
with Sarah Hyland like the wedding date
or some no but I saw the toasters
talking about it I would like to watch
it I've heard that it's like a good cute
movie oh also I watched falling in love
and I have to say like it was horrible
like really shockingly like you know a
Hummer
these are what they are because there's
an element of like terribleness to them
like they're not real they're not
academy-award like there's an element of
fraud in the sense that like you know
the set is fake like you know these
people are making a dollar like there's
a thickness to it and Netflix took that
fraud factor and exploited it like he
was everything was bad that acting was
bad the casting was bad like it was all
[ __ ] terrible said the only bright
spot was the New Zealand scenery which
was beautiful yeah
christina milian who i love he's no
actress I'm sorry like I was not buying
for one second anything that she was
selling the guy who played her love
interest was hot but again not really
anything special and the disagree on so
many weird things like the letters in
the in the wall like just trying to make
something happen
that random fire where everyone in the
town was mysteriously a firefighter like
it was just such a weird mess of a movie
I actually liked the entire movie and I
do think that Christina Milian ruined it
yeah like um it's sad because I loved
her I loved her and I liked it she it
was good movie I enjoyed it but it was
it could have been like really close to
perfect because I thought the setting
was beautiful the story was interesting
fixing up an in okay cool that guy he's
um from unreal and I guess he's a New
Zealander and like he had everything was
so like New Zealand and then she was
just like I don't know with her yoga
pants ie
he's from unreal yes they see the guy
from like the first season yes you know
he's a contestant and then he's like
hooking up with Rachel as is everyone
okay to just disagree with you on one
thing I don't think the movie was
perfect besides her like they were
getting a problem well he was really
strong and it was so I liked the setup
we're fixing up an inn where any to I
thought it was really cute and I think
in order for like a hallmark style movie
to have success it has to have three key
ingredients okay it needs to have a
decent pop decent it needs to have good
production value we had those two and it
has to have the leads being very
convincing in chemistry yeah and I just
didn't get that okay so is it two for
three you know and like the guy was was
perfectly New Zealand so yeah he was a
cute look Kiwi I'm assuming he's from
I hope well he just he convinces us that
accent on unreal something she can't
shake it yeah because it's yeah he's no
stratton actor okay yeah and that's why
the movie that i saw this weekend oh my
god sorry like when she gave that big
speech in the bank
wait why at the very end like when she
came she said no this is my home she did
it in the bank in front of like the
investor and the bank guy like it was so
weird yeah there was just so many weird
things yeah there were so many weird
things and also her boyfriend was from
unreal remember her boyfriend who came
to New Zealand yeah yeah from he's um
like a producer on The Bachelor of
unreal interesting yeah
so it's a very unreal that's weird weird
I thought that was me that's weird
thank you a cow no random maybe they
used the same casting um okay next story
Emmys tumble 33% to an all-time low
rating not shocking shocking awards have
hit an all-time low in the ratings
timezone adjusted ratings for Sunday's
telecast on Fox have the awards pulling
in six point nine million viewers down
almost a third 32% from last year's
Emmys ceremony on NBC the 10 point 21
million viewers was the previous low for
the awards so we are just going downhill
fast you know that's a huge jump I think
a lot of that definitely has to do with
not having a host I think like they they
promote and then do commercials and like
billboards for the Emmys around the host
so if there's no host like just a random
commercial for Emmys is not enticing I
literally forgot that it was on and if
it weren't for the fact that we were in
a hotel room looking for someone to
watch I wouldn't have remembered like
the marketing is all about the host and
last year was Sandra oh and a nice and
Sandberg which was like an interesting
thing and whether you liked it or not
people were tuning in because they
wanted to like see these this random
crew so I think it was a huge mistake
not to have a host they did have that
actor Thomas Lennon do like a voiceover
like between commercial breaks and stuff
people hated the voice oh yeah I thought
it was like silly it's like it's a host
so just get a [ __ ] host like yeah
don't go around with like this man in a
box you know I feel as though and some
of the late night errs
we call them the jimmies even I don't
think one of them was a Jimmy Colbert
was there they were talking about how
they've been ousted and all they know
how to do is host but no one wants a
hosting or the poor straight white man
we're hosts so oh yeah dresses for hosts
um but you could still have that get
snow and also no one wants to host
because like you don't get paid any
money everybody hates you and they'll
dig up all your own tweets and cancel
you and no matter what like even if you
do the best possible job people are
gonna say it was terrible right so what
is the reward there's none so no one
wants to even do it let alone they don't
want anyone to do it but they could have
you know people like more actors like I
don't understand why they don't have
like a me pole like Amy Poehler used to
do with a job my Tina Fey know people
still like them I wonder if they don't
want to do it or just like it's just
crazy I don't know thankless job I can't
imagine you get to a level like Amy
Poehler and you want to do that [ __ ]
trash yeah I need to like make fun of
like your friends in the audience yeah
they should really give it to like to
digital host see there who have no skin
in this game and like everybody hates
them already so like everything that's
actually a really good point I thought
it was a huge mistake and award shows
are always interesting baseline because
there's celebrities we love celebrities
we love to see them interact but they
were giving us like nothing to work with
you know can we talk about some of the
awards because like everyone from Game
of Thrones is nominated nobody want
except for Peter Dinklage again can I
tell you like a devastating factoid
Emilia Clarke has never won an Emmy for
her role as Daenerys Targaryen shocking
that's criminal yeah that's really
shocking she's like in all eight seasons
she once [ __ ] guys are ready for her
way yes she will actually like you can
always tell if someone thinks they're
gonna win like based on how they look
like if they look out of the world
extraordinary it's cuz they think
they're gonna win you know ya know she
was ready to win I was ready for her to
win and like she should have won Shyama
they should have come in blonde hair
Daenerys Targaryen is one of the most
iconic TV characters and book characters
but TV characters of all time do not win
an Emmy and I just have to tell you that
just makes the Emmys worth less they are
worthless
phillipe add one they really swept and
I'm not living under a rock but like I
hadn't heard about this show that much I
had I think we are living under a rock
but he did all her bread check I never
heard of her some things penetrate our
rock now you know and this didn't and I
know I'm sure it's an amazing show and
I'm sure every show that was not me like
I'm sure if I could watch it and get
through it
it's good fine but Game of Thrones was
on another level of course it was not
respected yeah
oh also um the actor from when they see
us won and they brought what some of the
I don't know if it was although the
Central Park five they were there like
imagine going from prison to the Emmys
like false incarcerated to the Emmys
like wow wow that's very well liked
actors are so serious you know and
there's just they take their craft so
seriously and being just like the way
they dress and the way they carry
themselves like it's so serious and I
felt even action more serious than usual
and it felt like so snotty especially
when they laughed at the Kardashians
like you're [ __ ] kidding me you're
all losers celebrities who would die the
chance to come to kris Jenner's like
[ __ ] party like they're all so
thirsty and then they they go to the
Emmys and they think that [ __ ] doesn't
stink and they're [ __ ] laughing at
the Kardashians
I left that you laura dern know and most
of these people in your limited series
like you're never coming to the Emmys
again for Chernobyl that moment like
really photo and like the center part 5
like you guys didn't yes yes but like I
just that moment really pissed me off
because like Hollywood is so thirsty and
like these people like they're they take
themselves so seriously to that at the
end of the day they're all obsessed with
that Hollywood [ __ ] and they would
like to anything to be like in with the
crowd of Kardashians and like you know
what they presented an award for reality
and no one makes more [ __ ] compelling
reality television for 17 years in the
Kardashians so I was just really try
starting a dialogue on Spanky and you
know what yeah I mean right and you know
what and they the most press that meets
have gotten is around the Kardashians
being laughed out like it's such
[ __ ] like I really that really
pissed me off
yeah it really pissed me off like it's
2019 have some respect for the
Kardashians for female entrepreneurs who
are making more money that half those
people combined and literally all of
Hollywood like relates back
the Kardashians like you're not anyone
yeah you don't have a connection to the
car that is so true like they are the
epicenter of the universe and [ __ ]
Hollywood hypocrites who laughed at them
a hundred percent I'm really pissed me
off
um but speaking of some positive news we
saw a photo of Kim Kylie and sophie
Turner and that is the friendship that I
need and I was thinking about it it's a
little too weird for Sophie and Kendall
because Kendall is really cheesy but
like sophie Turner would make the
perfect friend for Kylie yeah like so
elevated she loves Game of Thrones
she loves to drink like it said they
would have a good time you know but it
is about sophie turner like i really
believe that like both her public life
and her private life are very fulfilling
like i don't think that she like needs
certain friendships like i think some
parts of Kylie's life are emptied like
and you see that like with the loss of
Jordan and I think like she can use a
friend but I think sophie turner has
remained so cool and normal and like
everyone loves her because she has such
a fulfilling home personal and public
life that's true but I also feel and I
was thinking about the Jordan situation
when they were talking about it on the
show like I feel as though Sophia Ricci
has completely filled that hole and more
yeah like they're sisters they they're
like the sisters as possible she's a
perfect for her like she likes to have
fun to do the same things she's just
like the better Jordan for Kylie and
she's not gonna hook up with your
sisters man oh and you know what was so
interesting because she's already
hooking up with MADD when we were
talking about Jordan and the whole saga
months ago we were saying I think this
must be a really big blow for Kylie
because like the the way that are their
their family kind of values each other
and like that sister bond is the bond
that Kylie has with her friends she
almost values those relationships more
than she values the relationship with
her sister but she's a better wine
country I think this whole thing really
made her realize like what what the
Kardashians have known for years like
family is everything and and that's why
she was sitting there in the wine and
she was like I just don't know what I
would do without you guys like we're so
lucky to have each other it's like you
take something bad for you to realize
like the good but I think Kylie's now
firmly on the path of like family is it
tote and that's why she's investing so
much in Sophia because she could
potentially be family
yeah and I'm getting there with age
difference but um yeah it doesn't bother
me that much because she's like I'm
mature when you grew up in Hollywood I
just I think you're on a different
planet you are but like it's
weird she just turned 21 right all this
time at least she didn't just her 18
okay that would be like we wouldn't be
having this conversation yeah I'm
getting there and I and I I loved
getting really I do like them and I'm
really happy for she's getting there
well we'll get there soon okay next up
Jennifer Lawrence shares her Amazon
wedding registry in a surprisingly
thirsty movie ennifer Lawrence unveiled
her Amazon wedding registry today if you
ever wondered what the actress and plant
of his marriage must-haves are look no
further emotion like I know everyone
does charity but like what qualifies
Jennifer Lawrence to be a philanthropist
just quite like just seriously asking
like I don't know why they put that -
cuz I can't even and it's not
hyperlinked I can't even immediately
think of one cause she's like super
outspoken about yeah like every
celebrity I know Kaley Cuoco who loves
animals like everything I don't if I
donate to a GoFundMe like am i
philanthropist yeah no I'm just saying
like I feel like each celebrity is like
public with like a certain cause that
doesn't necessarily make them a plan
through this but I just want to know
what qualifies Jennifer Lawrence as a
philanthropist
yeah I don't know it's unclear very
weird way to describe her I feel like in
this whole Amazon thing like she
definitely had say and what the press
would be because I think like when you
do a brand partnership like you do press
yeah and she was like tossin
philanthropist yeah that's what we're
going with
the Oscar winner shared tasteful items
ranging from home entertaining smart
home outdoor and travel with over 49
chariot pieces there's definitely a
multitude of ways to emulate the Stars
cally cool home and lifestyle this is so
strange
it's obviously not her real registry
this is like something a bachelor
contestant does you like partnering with
Amazon sharing your registry and I'm
just curious but I guess like an Amazon
partnership it's like as big as it gets
no it's great I mean it's just so weird
for its you old for one for it to be but
forget for your little old for Amazon
back to school okay relax I think that
any Amazon partnership is welcome you
know like it's epic she doesn't even
have Instagram it's so weird just this
particular partnership that I'm really
feeling like I don't even know what to
say because everything I thought I knew
about Jennifer Lawrence is now gonna win
like yeah she doesn't submit to the
patriarchy she doesn't you know sell tea
like she's in her own hemisphere and
this is just not what you do when you
have your own hemisphere so I had to
imagine she got paid a lot how much I
would say like maybe a million dollars
more and then and that's enough to cover
her wedding right like she's got a
wedding to be versus you know they're
like didn't do so well yeah yeah that's
true so I'm I'm here for it but here's
like another interesting element because
this was the articles from E and they're
sharing the links to her Amazon and
there's a disclaimer that says yep we
love these products and we hope you do
too he has affiliate relationships so we
may get a small share of the revenue
from your purchases items are sold by
the retailer not right so when II like
hyperlinks products they get money from
it which is socially everyone's making
money that separates this that whole
thing what's called like advertorial
like advertising editorial that whole
concept is super weird to me because
like I remember when People magazine
wrote like the nastiest article about
summing navies launch they were like
linking products and at the bottom it
was like how have you buy any products
like we're gonna make money it's like
you're making money off of trashing
someone else's brand like it's such a
weird middle ground yeah it's so this
whole thing is weird and just makes you
question like their relation the
intentions yeah yeah that's odd so I
just wanted to disclaim you know if you
listen to the show they don't baby goes
into the show Thanks yeah okay next
story a little feel good news a little
philanthropy good news a little
philanthropy so a billionaire donor
sorry the article it's like you know
when they give excerpts as like the
title is a clean lone ledger for no
graduated I got creative but have you
read that you wouldn't click on it
billionaire donors pledged to Morehouse
College graduating class of 2019 will
wipe out thirty four million dollars in
student loan debt owed by students and
parents so Robert Smith is a businessman
but what does he do I am not sure what
he does but he was speaking at the
graduation of Morehouse universe
Morehouse College and he said that he
would pay off all the student debt and
student loans
240 million dollars and he just got the
final bill and it was 34 million dollars
Wow very cool that's very cool and
really putting all the other
billionaires to shame you know more than
400 new Morehouse College graduates
received emails emailed letters Friday
informing them of the amount of their
student loans that will be paid off by a
billionaire donor who pledged last
spring to wipe out the loan debt of the
entire graduating class of 2019
oh man this guy's totally gonna heaven
this is such a nice thing that's such a
nice thing to do like obviously
philanthropy is is good in whatever way
it comes but I just love when you can
see the change and not only that like
you're giving directly to the cause it's
like these organizations I'm sure a lot
of them are good you know I'm sure a lot
of them are a little shady and you don't
know like right it's it's it's all your
thing but I actually just saw a video on
tik-tok that was there's a website that
that's called spend Bill Gates's money
and you have all Bill Gates as money and
they have like a million things that you
could buy like NBA teams and FL teams
and he the person was making the video
and he bought every NFL team possible so
it was like 25 or whatever and Bill
Gates still had 16 billion dollars but
yeah and it was so interesting and it's
like that's crazy like I'm sorry if
you're Bill Gates and you're not wiping
out people's debts like you're a dick
okay I know buddy I'm Melinda Gates
Foundation yes and the gift something
which is like billionaires who pledge
half of all of their wealth to charity
and me and Margot we're in Seattle and
my show was in the Bill and Melinda
Gates Hall in the symphony sense right
so they're giving back by allowing
comedians because laughter is the best
medicine so cheers you know they do a
really good amount of therapy but I
don't know there's something so
especially like this day and age like to
me there's something so powerful about
just like that direct line of
philanthropy like starting your own
credit it's all good and I'm not trying
to knock but to me it's like I don't
know I'm so much more moved by like
Richard Smith
whatever his name is Roberts Robert
Smith like giving the money to these
these kids who just like want to start
their future with a clean slate then if
you started an organization that clears
people's dad do you know any mean yes
yes this is better I agree you know and
as he started
organization that clears - I completely
agree okay I'm glad there's a new
documentary on Bill Gates's on Netflix
that I watched a trailer for but wasn't
compelling enough for me to hit play
looks pretty interesting I think they
talked about his philanthropic work and
I'm sure it's amazing and moving I just
for some reason I'm so much more
impacted and like moved by this story
like and if this guy had started its
foundation like to clear people that's
like there would not be an article about
it yeah it's just like a rich person
doing what rich people do like starting
their own foundation but so that's why
I'm just so impressed by this I'm really
um I am no totally and now like 400 post
grad students like their lives are
changed their families are changed at
college funds like they won't be bogged
down for years with like the pressure of
student loans and like the interest
rates like these really gave these kids
like the gift of like a fresh start like
nobody has that like it's special and
even if his organization was doing it
for some reason like I just don't think
it's a special I agree like he did in a
cool way
yeah yeah totally look how are they
gonna get the money me and Margo were
watching America's Got Talent
in Canada like everything's delayed so
we were watching like the America's Got
Talent like finale like a few days later
and you know that amazing kid one who is
an amazing voice he was blind his thing
went viral yeah spoiler alert he won and
we me and i were like laying in bed with
tears in our eyes and we're watching the
lucas cinnamon know we're watching the
he wasn't even in the final show the
credits and Margo caught something it
said what did it say Margo it said that
it pays the 40 million dollar no the
million dollars a million dollars over
40 years how terrible is that and
remember after tax right right lovin on
the make-a-wish I wish they would change
that and I wish that more billionaires
would do the work that Robert Smith is
doing yeah and you know what I also wish
that Robert Smith's daughter is a
toaster so she knows all the nice things
we said about her dad totally are you
sick
um I don't know but this just happens to
me at 10:30 in the morning every weekday
knows that my nose runs yeah you have
like ice no I was just like wondering
where did that liquid come yeah I know
it came from
on your sleep I'm struggling over here
she can lay that on the couch it's like
I'm not sick it just it literally
happens a second I sit in this chair
maybe she's about to change when I get
up yeah but I'm gonna be blowing my nose
yeah that's the issue
okay well feel better so we're sorry
about that we're sorry is anyone ready
for the craziest story we might ever
report unleash I think I know what it is
the 22 year olds killer who is she 6 ok
classic tale this is Ukrainian camper
for short
Indiana mother who adopted a six year
old Ukrainian girl with dwarfism has
been charged with abandonment but the
mother claims her quote/unquote daughter
was found to be a 22 year old sociopath
masquerading as a child okay Christine
Barnett 45 an ex-husband Michael Barnett
43 have been charged with abandoning
their daughter when she was nine in
Lafayette Indiana and fleeing to Canada
an exclusive interview with Daily Mail
TV Christine denies the claims and says
she and Michael were victims of a fraud
claiming the girl they adopted was an
adult con artist who tried to kill her
Christine Michael agreed to the
emergency adoption of ukrainian-born
Natalia Grace in May 2010 from Florida
and they were told she was six
within a year Christine claims Natalya
tried pushing her onto an electric fence
poured bleach into her coffee and
threatened to stab the Barnett's in
their sleep sounds like someone needs a
spanking Natalia was treated by mental
health specialists who determined she
was an adult and pressed for the courts
to have her birth certificate changed in
2012 Marion County Superior Court in
Indianapolis decided Natalia was born in
1989 based upon medical evidence the
Barnett's moved to Canada and left
Natalia in an apartment it's like I
don't know which way the story is crazy
I know she six eyes she's 22 so I mean
and just like from my own opinion a
September 11th affidavit of probable
cause obtained by Daily Mail TV states
that experts carried out bone density
tests on Natalia in June 2010 and
concluded that she was eight years old
so it's still unclear oh wow that's
terrible because honestly until you said
that I thought for sure these people
like like this girl actually
was 20 so like we don't know anything
other than what has come out he said
they said she said from the Daily Mail
and now it's up to us to use our
imagining detective reasoning and I have
no [ __ ] clue well it's so hard to
adopt a kid like if you're gonna go
through all that paperwork and the
process and the visitations like I can't
imagine you're only doing it to abandon
the kid two years later right yeah it
says it has all the elements of a horror
movie an unsuspecting Christian couple
adopts an adorable little girl only to
discover she's an adult sociopath
masquerading as a child right so you can
you can make that movie one way or you
can make it the other way where it's
like this poor Ukranian orphan finally
think she finds the home that of her
dreams with this lovely Christian couple
until they end up abandoning her right
it's a tragedy it sounds like an episode
of SVU apparently this is this has been
a movie called orphan where a pigtailed
youngster oh my god to murder her family
when it's revealed she's 33 I forgot I
saw that movie [ __ ] not but how did
they get away with her being young and
being 30 like how did she look like a
child um did she have dwarfism I don't
know I didn't remember that a part of it
was that she was ended up thinking being
35 I thought she was just like an evil
child Oh didn't say that she ended up
being yeah yeah she's 33 it was I've
seen in my lifetime two scary movies The
Grudge and this movie and it's such a
scary movie like it's something about
kids being like [ __ ] up like gets me
all [ __ ] up
you know yeah but then also like this
could just be a genius defense for the
parents gee who did abandon the child
and like plenty yes adopting and
fostering children it's like such a
noble thing but there are so many
instances where the parents are unfit
yep where the children are neglected so
maybe they adopted a child mean even
with good intentions and maybe the child
was a troubled youngster and it's like
harder than they thought right and they
just abandon her and now they're saying
because she's 22 yeah well I hope the
kid finds a home if she's a kid yeah I
hope that we do get the truth of this
story and I think at the end of the day
I do hope she's 22 because the thought
of like an abandoned youngster in an
apartment a six-year-old in an apartment
in Indiana is like so sad no I know and
and how do you tell someone's age like
you're their teeth their teeth or like
her birth records from Ukraine
but I think the birth records like have
definitely been falsified at this point
like we gotta get a tooth also did she
ship
she had her that's what of the moms she
had a full pubic hair Bush and she had
her period that's what I read the whole
story lost a tooth morning this is what
made her think that like she's older
than she is okay okay crazy but
technically the mom could have made that
up and like also a jury didn't put that
detestable that is testable also like an
eight-year-old like having a period is
weird but it's not possible yeah it's a
having a full bush it's just like some
people develop really quickly that's
wait that story just got even crazier
any other factoids you'd like to share
with the class um she said that she
spoke like an adult like they went to
class like class where they choose like
gosh like I don't know how people deal
with these kids this is what the
six-year-old sentry from a sitcom like
the overly mature chai the precocious
child yeah that is so crazy show they
also quit miss she threatened to kill
them like stand over them but in their
sleep with a knife a child could do that
sure right yeah that's true that does
this it's not an adult make no so it's
just a crazy story I hope we get more
facts and I just need someone to snag a
tooth yes like just punch her in the
face no but they have to get it in a
legal way like I mean the courts can can
test it yeah it's just crazy right and
it like it so so if if this child is now
on trial and she is one way to exonerate
herself like by submitting her birth
records or whatever like wouldn't she
just do that well I think she's probably
22 yeah honestly because it's she's sad
if she's not ya know I mean for the fact
that we're laughing at this story like
she better be 2010 yeah because I really
think she is the possibility of her
being 8 and having been abandoned after
being adopted is literally too
heartbreaking for it to be true yeah
that's crazy oh my god so I think
officially the craziest story by the way
but also now the mom thinks that she's
she has is with another family doing the
same thing because they haven't seen her
last time they spoke she was making
for her new family eight-year-old makes
dinner
I hope the Daily Mail's I hope the new
family reads the Daily Mail they'll
email like sure like this is definitely
possible but it only comes to fruition
in the public eye because of things like
Daily Mail and their snapchat story like
they find the weirdest [ __ ] like
medical marvels random [ __ ] adoption
story it's like they have become like
the epicenter of weird news yeah it's
crazy
yeah and I'm grateful as am i and I look
forward to seeing this film adaptation
sometime soon or maybe sure it's already
happened maybe a limited series well now
that it's a true story it's different
sure a limited series but we don't know
how it ends yet
okay Dancing with the Stars you went
Chuck before we kept Dancing with the
Stars on an another note I was thinking
last night how I would never want to be
on Dancing with the Stars because as
much as I thought I could do it like I
didn't realize how much work it is like
you are literally dancing all day every
day before yeah all day every day like
torture like why do that when you could
just do open fit you know that's very
true because fall is coming with the
changing of leaves you should also come
a changing of you don't let the
temperatures be the only thing falling
this season take the plunge and lose
weight right at home with open fit don't
want to wait for your New Year's
resolution because that never works
start on a better you now with open fit
open fit takes all the complexity out of
losing weight and getting fit it's a
brand new super simple streaming service
that allows you to work out from the
comfort of your living room in as little
as 10 minutes a day I really enjoy it
because the shame of going to a gym is
just too much for me like I can't stand
seeing people and like the thought of
like someone videotaping me like not
that anyone cares like I just I can't
like I me and my agoraphobia are good we
choose to do everything at home we live
at home we shower at home we workout at
home no work walking around a locker
room I'm good you know yeah sculpt your
body in the community of your own own
home with no eyes on you it's affordable
and accessible you get what you put in
you can see results within the first 30
days if you want to just increase your
energy you want to put a pep in your
step or overall just feel better then
open fit is definitely worth in the shot
open fit has changed the way that we
workout and texting our code toast to 30
30 30 you can join us on our fitness
journey personalized just for you right
now during the open fit 30-day challenge
our listeners we got a special extended
30-day free trial membership to
and fit when you text toast to 30 30 30
you will get access to open fit fully
all the workouts and nutritional
information totally free again text
toast to 30 30 30 standard message and
data rates may apply love it but if
since you're not going on dancing it
sighs yeah the episode was really good I
felt like everyone improved a lot more
than I thought they were gonna bring
your mic
okay everyone improved so much I think
obviously like the the bright spot in
the whole episode which was actually
kind of dim was Lamar Odom like what
happened so he was being real like
really hard on himself and he went like
second to last and they showed in the
clip that PETA his partner was like you
keep asking me like about the steps like
you can't remember what comes next and
he's like I just had a lot of memory
lost from my accident and then he said
something that I don't think he's ever
said on TV maybe he said in his book but
I didn't read it where he swore that on
the night that he was out that bad bunny
ranch or whatever that he did not do
drugs that he was drugged and that's how
he overdosed he said I swear I did not
do drugs so I never had you heard that
before
no he was claiming that he was drugged
into an overdose which I don't know if I
necessarily believe but um nonetheless
it was still really sad and he like
really [ __ ] up like he just could not
remember anything stats but he was like
having fun and he like loosened up and
when he went backstage to do an
interview there and Andrews he was like
so obviously disappointed and like
discouraged and he was like the way that
it works is like the judges vote and you
get like a number but then also the fans
vote so he really put on the performance
of a lifetime being like such a sad-sack
that I think I everyone I know just like
I think I may be in first place
you know he's by the way they'd call
names he's the first one out like if
you're real particular order but still
it was shocking they were like the jokes
read to a bar last night there's no
doubt in my mind I was facetiming with
my friend at least yeah and her mom and
they were both texting Lamar Lamar you
can vote up to ten times like it was he
was so sad he said he was like I feel
like I just lost I feel like I am going
home like that was in this post
interview after his dance and he was
just like so sad like how could you send
someone home after no you can't yeah
there's something about the show that
makes everyone like inherently likeable
like it really is a struggle and unless
you're like Allie Brooke or Lauren
Alaina
Hannah Brown who dancing comes like
really naturally to you it's really hard
and I think that like it really kind of
humanizes everyone likes Saylor Brinkley
it's having a hard time like she's not
the type of girl who just like took
dance lessons and it's like a free
spirit dancing yeah she's uncomfortable
in her own skin and like she's working
really hard it's just such an I can't
leave I never watched him before because
it's really like a weird interesting
show and you would have loved last
night's episode because james Van Der
Beek danced the foxtrot and he was
talking about how there was actually a
storyline that don't trust the B in
apartment 23 where his character went on
Dancing with the Stars and did a Foxtrot
but he accidentally took mushrooms at
his hands were made of pound cake
and they were like showing back the
clips from don't trusted me and he's
like I said it's like do it for real and
he did a good job
people are like obsessed with him like
they think it's like the second coming
of Jesus like he's the best after he's
like normanni and like he's fine
as a dancer people obsessed with dance
no as a dancer no I just don't think
anybody expected him to be as good as he
was so it's easier for a guy to be
better because when you're doing like a
couple's ball yes the girl is the focus
point like she does the stunts and like
the flips and the tricks and the guy is
very much like the leader so I just
don't think it's as impressive for james
van der beek to be at the leaderboard
like to me what's so impressive is
Hannah brown like she looks you can't
tell who's the pro well you literally
cannot tell who's the pro but I just
have one complaint with Dancing with the
Stars what this singing there oh my god
yes so they have like an in-house band
excuse me
and they do like their own versions of
popular songs so like they did confident
lover type and I would say like half the
time it's actually beautiful like it's
like a wedding band and half the time
like it is the most tone-deaf brokedown
piece of trash
ever how come shocking would you buy the
right song no no I like that they have a
band like it's like a wedding it's like
these weird stripped-down versions it's
exactly it's like a wedding they should
have Miriam Bennett who did both of our
weddings she's the most talented singer
ever like they should have her been
because it should be better it could be
like you can have the best man in the
biz that's actually I think that's the
job for Miriam Bennett and even though
she's like literally booked for the next
five years with weddings but she that is
the job for her yeah she crushed it and
she's so like lively and like full of
personality like she really takes over
the wedding because like she's this
energy like power source no too
she's a power so that's a great call
Jackie I like that um Ali Brooke um so
this was like the episode where like
everyone got their thing do you not I
mean like you watch clips and it's like
every Ali was saying and I don't easily
demean anyone's experience with bullying
but like it was just like so obviously
playing here I go no but like she was
like you know people like would say that
I was the worst answer if it's harmony
and they would like put clips in me
dancing together and like really shame
me for it and it's like I was a
harmonizer like I could tell you that
never happened like I mean I really
don't mean to demean someone's but she
was just like not latching on because
like bullying is like this it's like a
movement now like yeah and she was
really like like hitching her horse to
like this movement and it was just like
such a stretch and again I I feel bad
like - meaning someone's experience with
bullying but like I could just it was
like fake I'm sorry like I knew that
tensed oh but she was just like really
weirdly like trying hard to like make
this a moment where like with the tears
and then after she was dancing like the
judges were like you are a dancer and
she was like that means so much to me
like badly that's how to cheat a lot
that means trash compared to nor money
like who right now is the best dancer in
history doesn't mean that Ali Brooke
isn't a dancer or a good dancer
I don't know and also it's like you
could say like maybe you felt some type
of way about like being compared to all
these other girls but like that's not
necessarily bullying it's like that
movie tall girl it's like she was so
insecure and like had so much going on
but I don't think she would ever say
like I'm bullied you know even though
she was bullied yeah you don't have to
be bullied in order to like feel badly
about yourself you know sometimes it's
just like something today
yeah and that's best and that's
relatable - yeah you manifest that as
bullying when it's actually just your
own insecurities yeah and then you start
to perceive things yeah I just think
they weren't bullying is like a strong
buzzword that like now it's a real
serious issue but people like used when
it's not applicable and I just thought
that was like a really weird thing and I
didn't like it and last year I was on
here I mean last week I was on here
defending her that she deserved better
scores I mean she got better scores but
I don't think she dance is good but
whatever
Lauren Elena is the most solid person
out there like she has grown like she is
exactly who should be on the show like
she's coordinated but she doesn't have
dance experience really and she's
getting better every week and she still
is
really good I think she's really gonna
make it very far Hannah Brown is like
the leader of the pack like she got the
first eight like I I can't believe like
how good of a dancer she is I'd she
dance to love her yeah I can't believe
how good of a dancer she is like she was
doing lifts and spins and everything she
was a she's a pro like and she chooses
the cutest outfits like I don't know if
they have input but like she is very in
charge like of her makeup and and it
always working really well and I think
they're trying to like make us think
that she's gonna start dating her
partner I think that she can't stand him
uh you know what he's not my favorite
like yeah at all and I wouldn't ship
them um the woman who went home which it
was the woman I was talking about last
week Mary Wilson she was one of the
Supremes and I just say she was a lot
better and I didn't really feel like it
was fair that she went home because in
actuality Lamar should have gotten home
but he just got so many votes and like
none of the young people who watch
chancing with the stars know who Mary
Wilson and like maybe she could have
said something compelling that would
make you all want to vote for her she
was a little too proud um but her and
her partner like definitely despise each
other because like they were dancing to
Aretha Franklin and he didn't really
know hurry the Franklin was because he
was like there's like five generations
between us like he was being a dick
honestly I'm glad they're gone because I
didn't like her and I really didn't like
him honestly then come
Kurama sorry he did amazing like he
actually has a lot of potential to he
wears great outfits that guy Len who is
like the mean judge he's like the Simon
Cowell
he's [ __ ] annoying actually like he's
my favorite what I mean Bruno I'd say I
think all the judges are actually
terrible and they really need to clean
house like they had Julianne Hough on
and she was on America's Got Talent
which is I think maybe why she didn't
come back to Dancing with the Stars
because that of AGT money is legit for
sure it's good enough for Howard Stern
but it's like they're they're all like
ballroom dancing professionals and
they're so uninteresting and they're so
not funny and I'm really like I really
don't let the judging is actually we
were sorry for part horse because I
don't agree with the judging and I don't
like the panelists and I feel like they
can have like two young Milania morning
show host and like that would really
screws things out yeah but like Julianne
Hough like Derek Hough like people
should be there there are famous dancers
like they should be there totally who
are actually classically trained some
just some of the comments about the
bullying conversation they just want to
mention is someone
that I think if someone feels they were
bullied they were bullied and I how come
I have to say like I just disagree oh
yeah I'm sorry like cuz then you can say
that about anything right and then the
sort of loses its value and like real
bullies and real people being bullied
and it's not something to take lightly
and I only learn that from watching the
Real Housewives are you oh my god say
you don't watch them maybe like maybe I
would have agreed with this person but
like the women whenever they hear
something that they don't like they just
say that they're being bullied and that
doesn't mean that they've been bullied
I agree just cuz they're being called
out on their [ __ ] or because they're
feeling insecure about certain things
and it's like heightened but it's not
actually a bully thing it's more of an
insecurity thing right so I just think
the word bully is not something that you
can just apply to yourself like because
you feel uncomfortable and that everyone
else should agree because then we could
just be bullied all the time oh Sean
Spicer was there and he was actually
kind of funny he wore like the most
horrible lime green shirt last week and
someone in wardrobe cut him a break
because he wore like a normal blazer
which is obviously what he's comfortable
in and you know what he was he got so
much better like yes so decent but like
it's just clear like the odds are
stacked against him like you know what I
really like but I kind of feel like the
contestants are vibing I think people
talk about the judges it's like this
awkward elephant in the room that
they're not really addressing but I
don't know I
Kurama like everyone seems to really be
getting along with him and that's what
he said that's what he meant was like
this show humanizes people yeah because
they can you to see him out here like
working hard and like trying to like get
in shape and I don't think the judges
like him I think everyone feels really
uncomfortable around him but I think
he's like doing a good job of like
making the best today yeah I just like I
don't know every time I see you like I
can't imagine that like this is easy fun
it's just what he says pretending like
looking like he's having fun you know
he's faking it til I makes I think he's
really relieved he wasn't the first one
to go home because I think because it
was backlash about him come yeah and I
think he was probably thought he was
gonna be like the the first person to go
home and I think like now he just wants
to like not embarrass himself and just
make it as far as possible he knows he's
not gonna win
yeah but he doesn't want to be
embarrassed and not be going home the
first week is embarrassing now he's fine
yeah well no matter what happens same
with the morning but like oh my person
and that's what we said last week like
last week was gonna be the worst week
and then it kind of like like if they
don't address the elephant in the room
like it just lets you move on from it
like the green shirt of it all and now
he's just like another contestant right
he's not but he is but like yeah also my
favorite underrated person on the show
contestant is Ray Lewis okay he was in
the bottom two he was in the bottom two
when I thought for sure he was going
home I'm like they're not gonna send a
75 year old woman home but they did and
for that honesty I'm I was grateful
because Ray Lewis it's like I'm the 75
year old woman home week one like when
she stood no chance why even have her on
yeah again Valley Brook is not fair no
and so either you give her that likely
way you would've heard like extra room
yep or or not at all and then usually
that's called like a handicap when
someone gets like a little few extra
points but I don't know if we're saying
that anymore I don't think I don't but I
can't people say in golf all the time I
don't like to a point you know when
you're like a kid and the thing about
Ray Lewis is like he's not a good dancer
and he can't get the steps right but
he's having so much fun out there like
smiling he's he's like this big goofball
like I watch him and I'm laughing like I
really when I thought he was going home
I was actually upset because I wouldn't
miss him like he has a lot of charisma
and him and his partner really get along
and he's trying really hard but that
would lend mistake for people like Lamar
and this fella player ray Lou it's like
it is so hard like they're so tall their
brain by the time their brain tells
their foot to do something it's like ten
seconds later I feel like that first
sailor Brinkley also like models aren't
I think she's like the first model to
ever go on the show models aren't
dancers yes they're very awkward she's
not that tall though like she's a model
she is but she's she's like Sports
Illustrated she's like fast she's very
like average height she came on the
breath yeah he weren't there she was
very tall okay compared to us like her
partner like she doesn't tower over him
I think they might be the same size like
she's really not aggressively tall but
she was really awkward this week because
they did the Rumba which is like the
sensual like whatever and her boyfriend
was in the audience like they grew up
together and she was like so visibly
uncomfortable in the dance senorita yeah
this is the worst performance of
senorita I've ever heard like the girl
could not hit a note if her life
depended on it
um it was just really awkward and like
she I feel like she's an awkward girl
like she's just not like an extrovert so
I think she's struggling and she didn't
much time as everyone's like get
acquainted like she's doing a good job
but like she easily could have been
going home you know
oh also there's so many contestants the
most quiet like unsung hero is clay cake
fan Flannery from the office do you know
where red hair she was on the office she
was like a totally random character she
was alcoholic like weird to nature and
she she's truck she's doing so good
she's got one of the highest second
highest score she's just like really
like getting in quietly like in really
making moves and and and everyone really
likes her and her personality and the
clips from from rehearsal like she's
[ __ ] funny I think she might be a
comedian because she's hilarious cool
yeah it's really like you guys are
enjoying I mean yeah it's really
enjoyable I was looking forward to
having the two hours on Mondays after
The Bachelor so I'm a little let down
about that but Jessica the stars only
once a week right yeah yeah is it two
hours yes but it's not so much filler
it's like there's a lot of commercials
but it's like they come back from
commercials and they can't it's like yes
no like we took a trip this week you
know like it's just it's good yeah it's
television as a lot of content
entertainment yeah oh and a million
people in the audience like I said food
God was there without LeBrock which I
didn't really understand
no Katie Colton Cassie Demi Jeff any of
Colton yeah trying to get on camera in
the monitor like he was standing behind
the host and it wasn't sure if he was
gonna be on TV so him and Cassie movie
no chance for it was hilarious
honestly relatable Chris Harrison was in
the audience
Oh Robert Herjavec and Kym Herjavec
we're in the audience like they really
get good celebrity and like relevant ABC
talent in the front row and I that's
actually my favorite part like seeing
who's just like Shane Lee in the
background and they don't address it so
it's like Tom the host is standing there
with the microphone and food god it's
right there and it's like you're
supposed to just think it's normal
who was he there for Oh Brooke I was so
weird totally yeah I'm really enjoy the
show
me too I'm happy for you guys about to
blow deck but you didn't so we'll talk
about it later there's Arnie and we have
tomorrow we have Stephanie home in from
the Real Housewives of Dallas which is
really exciting we're gonna be asking
her all about this week's episode of
Dallas anything you want to ask her we
will post on Instagram then Thursday we
have v1b only sick Baker from Blue
Bloods I'm so excited
for my blue-blooded Steen's which is a
subgroup on facebook of like a literary
3pl be margo at a lot of paris it's okay
a baker who police Tom Selleck's
assistant oh let's have a good walk but
she plays Abigail Baker yeah but
whatever her name he's a baker in my
eyes she plays Tom Selleck's chief of
staff and she's like this important like
character staple in the show and she's
gonna come here talking about Blue
Bloods with us which I'm really excited
about he comes back on Friday oh my god
it does yes ten even prepared this is TV
season oh my god it's feeling like soon
Riverdale dynasty oh my god wait me and
Margaret Vancouver trying everything in
our power to get to the Riverdale set
and we didn't but we went to parlor for
dinner which we heard a lot of the
Riverdale set frequents but then we
found out that it's Emmys weekend and
that a lot of the Riverdale kids weren't
in town like Camilla Mendes was in yeah
but we went to dinner at parlour and we
think we know we really don't know II
think we saw writer Ross like we were
sitting right next to him but we think
that if it was him he would have said hi
to us I don't know who didn't think
you're out if he was him or not Margaret
cheese Loki took a picture we were like
sitting at dinner giggling images but um
so we think we did it it could have been
I literally changed my mind every five
seconds I don't know well if any of the
toasters know whether or not he was that
parlor on Friday Saturday let us know um
so yes two premium guests to speak
Stephanie home and tomorrow and then
Thursday Abigail Baker
I've got hawk but she goes my Baker now
and thank you guys so much for being
here listening to the morning shows it's
been an absolute pleasure hanging out
with you if you know you know the
morning trusses and Lenny all morning
show people live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching on YouTube feel free to
give this video a thumbs up subscribe
share to a friend you know do what you
got to do put the little notifications
on um we're also available as a podcast
which if you're listening to us a
podcast you obviously already know that
we're available we're we available
iTunes itunes but sighs Spotify States
at your Public Radio I crazy a cast box
should check it out subscribe over there
leave a five star review about how
beautiful we are and smart and
intelligent how well research this show
is we love you I'm Claudia joy girls on
job tickets are available to my upcoming
shows which are mostly sold out except
for San Diego and Los Angeles tickets
available car with no job comm we'll see
you tomorrow
by
you